I'm really delighted to be here and
uh, hope we can have a dialogue, uh,
after I speak a little bit about my
book. Um, so yeah, far from scaring you,
I think I want to reassure you initially
that creating a is really something
that we all do every day of our lives.
It's one of the most fundamental
biological processes. And to frame that,
it's pretty clear that there's hardly
a condition and the course of your day
that you encounter that's
fully predictable or predicted,
you encounter it and you act in
a fundamentally creative way.
You go right there,
you go left.
And that may be a trivial
creative act or a consequential,
a trivia creative act.
But in any case,
it matters to you in the moment that
you do it or you wouldn't have done it.
Occasionally those creative acts lead
to creative things and those created
things may be anything from
a well articulated sentence
to a pure wet to a book.
And those things matter to you when you
create them or you wouldn't create them.
Now it has turned out to be in our
interest to create not only for ourselves,
things that matter,
but also things that matter
for many of those around us.
The clan and the wellbeing of the clan
tends to correlate with our own personal
wellbeing.
And therefore over time,
our biology has pushed us to think
about creating things that matter,
not just to ourselves right now but to
others and for a fairly long period of
time. And so if you look over the course
of human history at created things,
whether it's an equation or a wheel,
uh,
these things have tended to, uh,
involve of course, collaboration,
a discussion,
kind of figuring out what matters to
the clan and pooling of resources. And,
and when we finally made something,
we've tended to make it to last,
not just for the moment when we created
it for some relatively long period of
time. And therefore villages
and pyramids and shoes, uh,
tended for most of history
to last quite a long time.
Fast forward to where we are today and
we're in a moment that in a way is the
pinnacle achievement of human creativity.
And if you read Steven Pinker's
recent book, clearly, uh,
by most indicators,
the human condition is better off today
by human creativity than it ever has
been.
But one of the uniquenesses of our
moment is that the created things that
surround us are remarkably short lived.
And the reason for that is a multiple,
firstly among the things that we have a
limited supply of his time and therefore
in all of history when we have and
have had a chance to create something a
tomorrow versus creating something that
matters to us the day after tomorrow,
we sort of focus on tomorrow time matters.
And over the last 300 years,
and especially over the last 30 years,
the power of science and technology has
made it possible to create things of
mass utility really rapidly.
And it's led to this increasing focus
on creating things over a really short
period of time.
And that's skewed our perception of what
creativity is and really led me to the
writing of this book. It's
also created, of course,
this situation a highlighted by the
United Nations and their identification of
the 17 sustainable development goals
of a world that is in a risk of,
uh, no sustainability and
therefore many today are focusing,
whether it's on feeding the planet or
saving life in the sea or preserving the
environment in some way on creating
over a long period of time.
Now I'd like to just talk
for a little bit about, uh,
creating and this concept of learning.
If you think about the sort of
canonical, uh, creator environment, uh,
you probably think about a
scientific lab, which is indeed, uh,
responsible for much of the,
created a world around us today.
And if you think about what
happens in a scientific lab,
you probably have in mind the
scientific method. And indeed,
the scientific method is one of the
things that goes on in a science lab.
We tend to focus on phenomena
whose laws we understand. Uh,
we frame those phenomena in conditions
that are really well specified and we
apply the scientific method and we observe
and to do so. And we make discoveries.
However, in pioneering work, uh,
in science and engineering
and other domains,
we tend to have either not perfect
understanding of the phenomena nor perfect
understanding of the
conditions that frame them.
And as much as analysis and
deduction matters in the science lab,
actually intuition and
imagination matters too.
And therefore the scientific process and
science labs or an engineering labs and
labs generally is a combination of the
classical scientific method and what I
call an artistic method.
It blends this induction deduction,
a comfort with uncertainty and ability
to frame a problem and move on into a
single process that over the last 10 or
15 years I've been talking about as an
art science process. Now,
if you take the metaphor,
the science lab and you apply it to
your lives here at Google or to your
personal lives,
this balance of art and science still
holds and there's probably a lot more art
that, uh, is involved in science. And
you can take any example. An example,
for example,
of losing your watch.
You make a hypothesis that you're
watching is under your bed.
You then test your hypothesis
by looking for, you're watching,
you make a discovery and so on and so
forth. And that's generally how we, uh,
encounter,
um,
opportunity and a need in our lives
and by this balance of art and science.
Now in my book, I talk about, um,
this notion of an aesthetic work or
aesthetics and a lot of thinking over the
last century, particularly
around aesthetics as being, uh,
closely coupled with a kind
of mindful way of living.
And if you look at the most
mindful of experiments,
the works that come from those, whether
it's a scientific article or a relief,
um,
can be thought of as aesthetic works.
And I'd like to talk about aesthetics were
aesthetic works just for a little bit.
If you look over the course of history
at, uh, things that we've made, um,
through experimental processes,
whether they're books or plays or,
uh, reliefs, uh,
they have generally invited a reaction
from the public of observation,
uh, and learning. Uh, and, uh,
that has led to how we structure
our universities, our museums,
and even our companies and
stores. If you look, however,
at the last 30 years or so at cultural
works and a works of technology indeed.
Um,
as you produce here at Google,
they invite a very different
kind of public experience.
This here is an image from Olafur.
Eliasson is 2004,
a weather project at the Tate modern.
Uh,
a kind of son was created and the, um, uh,
Tate modern and, uh, people were
invited to observe. And of course,
nobody had any idea how people
would observe an x to the,
ended up laying on their backs and
they ended up making formations.
There's a whole story about how
the weather project was a lived,
but they became part of the,
uh, the, uh, the cultural work.
And that's indeed what's
happened in technology in media.
If you look at something
like a smart phone, uh,
as which invites me to
engage in my engagement,
changes the phone in a certain way,
just as Google has changed
by me using Google.
And so there's this increasing
participation of the public, uh,
with the creator and we're all
kind of creating a together.
And I say all of that just to say
that the notion of learning, um,
indeed,
even of commerce as being one of a
producer and a consumer is going away and
it's actually has a radical impact and
how we think about learning at Harvard
University and ultimately,
um, probably doing business.
And so I've been focused over
the last 15 years on the, uh,
synonymous nature of, uh, learning, uh,
about tomorrow and creating tomorrow.
And, uh, particularly focusing on,
among other things a little kids. My book
begins with a story about a little kid.
Uh, if you think about the ultimate
pioneers, um, they are little kids, right?
They're encountering conditions that are
radically new and they are learning at
an rate. And if all is, uh,
particularly supportive,
they're having fun.
And so this is something that I come
back to very frequently with being
motivated, not for a commercial purpose
or for making a name for themselves,
but they're just sort of
fascinated, super curious and, uh,
and they're learning now, particularly
in my book, I focus on pioneers,
pioneering creators who are creating
of a very long period of time.
And actually in quite risky
and uncertain conditions.
And I focus on the emotive and cognitive
dimensions that lead to not only
successful pioneering, creating,
but also a deep pleasure.
And to give you just a little insight,
one of the creators who I spent time with,
David [inaudible],
who's one of the great
marine photographers of our
time and invented the split
screen or the split Lens for
photographing above and below water.
And I was talking to David about the
quality's important in a buddy, uh, in,
in diving deep into the ocean.
And just to point out,
as I'll mention more here in
the last part of my talk, uh,
when we pioneer, uh, we tend
to pioneer best not alone. Uh,
and now we're not
clearly not in a village,
but we tend to have a team of buddy and,
uh,
who's thinking of our interest and we are
thinking of her interest in that tends
to maximize or optimize our survival.
And it's obviously true in diving
in the ocean. I asked Dave,
but what are the qualities that
matter most to you? And he said, well,
the second most important probably,
which was interesting, uh,
that he started with that
was that they'd be kind,
and it's kind of nothing worse than
diving with somebody and kind of risking
your life with somebody who
is just fundamentally not
kind. And, uh, so I said,
well, what's the first most important,
uh, quality? And he said, well,
they need to be passionately curious.
And so obviously at a frontier,
if you're not a waking up and
motivated to, uh, explore that,
nobody will be right. So this
passionate curiosity, empathy,
these are the kinds of emotive and
cognitive interventions that I focus on in
the book. And I look at creators like
Ferran Adria, the chef of El Bulli,
uh, which closed down in 2011, arguably
the greatest chef living today.
And I look at their creative
process from great scientist,
uh, living today to great
inventors, uh, to artists.
And I show that all of them follow
a very similar, uh, process.
Uh, they may, uh, all do
really well economically.
They made create a amazingly
successful companies,
or it amazingly successful
a music theater. Uh,
and yet, uh, what's driving
them is something else actually,
and it's related to the reward,
uh, system, uh, of our brains.
And you are all probably aware of,
but just to remind you,
there are three fundamental
processes, um, uh,
motivate us through the reward
system. One is a wanting process. Um,
one is a reinforcement learning
process and one is a liking process.
And an illustration of this very
simply would be Anna Karenina.
Let's say I'm a told to for my class or
for some other reason want to read a Leo
Tolstoy's Anna Karenina. There's some,
uh, pleasure actually and wanting, uh,
anything and particularly wanting
to read Anna Karenina. I read it.
So there's this reinforcement
learning. I began to like, uh,
Anna Karenina and finally
having finished the book,
I really like it so much that I talk
to my wife about Anna Karenina and we
exchange ideas. And when I go to read my
next book of Leo Tolstoy War and peace,
uh, I have been informed through
that conversation with my wife.
And that kind of cycle of how we learn
is really the cycle of how we create.
And so in Ferran Adria as case from the
ideating to the experimenting to the
serving of a, an amazing dish, this cycle,
um,
in all of the creator lives that
I describe a is fundamental,
not only to learning the kinds of
dimensions that I mentioned, the empathy,
the passion and others that
I'll mention in just a minute,
but also creating value that
they bring to the public.
There's a conversation much like
what happens with the Internet and,
uh,
and everyone learns and then they go back.
And not only is that a formative
for the creative thing,
this new thing that the
world has never seen before,
which goes through this cycle of
communication with the public,
but it's actually deeply pleasurable.
So in my book,
I highlight these emotive
and cognitive dimensions,
which are pretty contrasted to the emotive
and cognitive dimensions that we tend
to celebrate and culture
and, and maybe, um,
inculcate in our businesses
and our business schools.
And so it's clear that in,
uh,
the success of a Google or the
success of a, even my book,
uh,
both sets of qualities are important.
There are times where we're at battle.
Uh,
and there are times where
we are discovering and the
qualities that lead to the
successful warrior are pretty defiantly
not the qualities that lead to the
successful pioneer. And one of the
challenges in writing a book or,
um, uh, bringing great value to, uh,
to the world in a company like Google
is how do you balance these two?
In my book, I am focusing mostly
on this patch of blue and,
and a and read, uh, and this, the,
the cycle of creating that allows for
these qualities to be learned and we
learned and, and ultimately
shared. Now, if I ask you, uh,
what are the qualities and the neighbors
you'd like to live with? I can imagine,
which, I'm sorry. I hope I can imagine
which a set of qualities they are.
And one of the points in my book
is while we are interested today,
obviously in creating things that mattered
to many over a very long period of
time, this future that we're
all looking for is really, uh,
starts today, right? And it's,
and it's as much as it relates to this
thing that you're mattering, it makes,
it relates even more fundamentally
to how you ate this thing, right?
And so this a way of living,
uh,
uh, passionate curiosity, empathy
and tuition in a sense of humility,
all of which I described more
fundamentally in the book is, is, uh,
is critical, I believe, to
introduce into our schools,
into our companies and into interculture.
And indeed in my book,
uh,
I talk about how that's happening.
So the last part of my book,
uh,
emphasizes the grassroots
Creator Movement,
which I identify as beginning around
the time of the first tweet, uh,
the first maker Faire make magazine,
uh,
over the last 10, 15 years as
you've thrived here at Google, uh,
the world has radically changed,
as we all know.
But one of the things that's most striking
to me is that over a short period of
time,
much of the planet has now placed itself
in a position of creatively expressing
itself in a way that
never happened before.
And expressing itself in ways that endure.
Much of this creation may be viewed by
many as trivial or not interesting or
even, um, profoundly irritating. Uh,
but it is fundamentally and in
many cases not to make money,
not to make a name,
although that happens,
but to express oneself and express
an experience that one has had,
that aesthetic creation
is I think fundamental to
creating the world that we all
wish to live in. And indeed, it's
starting to re, uh, structure how we,
uh, how we, how we run companies. Uh,
the kinds of environments that
companies are thriving in.
And it's quite reflected by
your own, uh, your own campus.
And so I've been very involved.
I've opened a restaurant in, in,
in Cambridge and have my
students making things.
And so I'm really interested in
this grassroots create a movement.
And one of the things that fascinates
me and I talk about in the book is that
we're seeing this self
association that creators, um,
grassroots creators, um, make and uh,
these happen online obviously,
but they also happen in a,
in physical environments.
And these could be habitat for humanity
kinds of gatherings where they could be
weekend food, making a gatherings.
These could happen in classes,
lots of maker activities.
But these are often self associations
of creators who want to create together,
maybe write fiction together.
And they come together really very
frequently for the pleasure of creating
together.
And they learn as I write in the
book these same qualities, uh,
these aesthetic dimensions
of creating that are, um,
not only fundamental to creating a over
a very long period of time but having
fun and,
and a personal self satisfaction.
So I'm going to end really
quickly here by talking about a,
uh, to, uh, innovation,
um,
activities that I've been very engaged
with over these 15 years as I've been
learning myself and
creating environments that
foster this kind of learning.
And, uh, one of these, um,
relates to my work in Africa
in the early two thousands.
I was one of the first grand challenge,
um,
gates grand challenge grantees and
was focused on a inhaled vaccines and
antibiotics for a tuberculosis set up,
a not for profit and South African.
I became struck by the
middle two thousands.
There was relative affluence coming to
Africa by these mounds of trash that
we're growing outside of the cities and
this sort of importation of diseases
that we thought.
Until then,
we're fundamentally developed world
diseases like cardiac and depression and
other kinds of illnesses. And shifted
my work for many other reasons,
to food and to, uh,
to, uh, ultimately, uh,
for a significant amount of my
creative time to food packaging.
And I came up with this idea that well,
we really should make a packaging like
nature makes packaging and the ultimate
water bottle is the coconut and a,
and so I began to reflect
on how that would be done.
Now this was for many years a curated
in a cultural context where we did an
exhibition in Paris at the level of 12,
this cultural center
that I opened in 2007.
And a invited the public to,
uh, eat water bottles. And,
uh, for, uh, two or three years.
This, uh, kind of Wiki food, uh,
was a cultural experiment and we
set up an underground restaurant in,
in Paris and a,
this led to accompany a eventually
and to products, um, uh, that, uh,
sell particular on the east coast and
ultimately to this product of which I have
some here, which you can now
make any fruit in the form, uh,
or any food really in the form of grapes,
uh,
and a and the product that is now launched
and that you can taste or a fruit,
kids are not eating fruit anymore because
the trend is going down because fruit,
um, you sort of complicated to, uh, eat
and parents are concerned about skins,
but you can remake fruit, uh, with
these edible, um, packages if you will,
or skins. Uh, and this
work now through, um,
uh, a number of collaborators
is, is moving to, uh,
a, uh, an effort in Africa,
particularly in Sierra Leone, uh,
to develop a local food forums,
uh, that are environmentally
sustainable and that are highly,
uh,
in fact, derived by, by micro nutrients.
So what began as an idea in Africa moved
through a cultural environment for a
time that might've been an in determinant,
certainly was, uh, in the process,
became a company,
a venture backed company,
and is now coming back to Africa all
through a process that kind of needed to
have this open ended, uh, and um, uh,
driving force that was other
than pure commercial interests.
Now just finish by saying that I've
also been interested in since my first
company, uh, related to
inhaled insulin and, uh,
delivering health and wellness to the
air and have become fascinated since the
Nobel prize in 2004 with
the revolution happening in,
uh, in, in mill factory biology. Uh,
the largest sub class of the human
genome is the olfactory receptor subclass
olfactory receptors and not just in
your nose there throughout your body.
And so this is amazing conversation that's
going on since soreally inside of you
that we understand now is fundamentally
related to olfaction and clearly, uh,
plays a major role in metabolic health
and neurologic health and getting that
right. Um, uh, we believe
is partly related to,
um, uh, writing.
Some of the metabolic and neurologic
dysfunction that's happened here over the
last 30 or 40 years.
And so we've developed a platform for
digitizing scent and began to work and
collaborate with Questlove and thinking
about synesthesia and, and, uh,
how these kinds of, um,
experiences can, uh,
improve, uh, wellbeing and, and, uh,
experience with, um, even of, uh,
music, uh, and ultimately
come into work environments,
looking how sensory design can improve
the workspace. And finally, um,
we're coming out with
our first real, um, uh,
mass market product here this year,
uh, which I can share with you,
which is a way of, uh,
creating flavor images, um,
either autonomously or over any food
you can kind of color any food with a
flavor of chocolate or
popcorn or a or rum.
And, uh, and then in consuming that
food, your brain tells you that.
That's just what I've had.
And so it's a really interesting way
to address some of the food addiction
issues that we're dealing with
today. So once again, this, uh,
project began it blue sky actually
with some of my students, uh,
developed in a cultural environment for
a long period of time and finally, uh,
through commercial forces is
moving into the marketplace.
So I'd like to just end by saying that
these sorts of culture lab environments
that began to show up in Europe and
the middle two thousands are now
increasingly I'm showing
up in companies like yours.
I view what I know of Google and
uh, in part does a culture lab. Uh,
we moved the level of cultural
lab to Cambridge in 2014
and began the world frontiers forum and
the World Frontiers Forum as a gathering
of leaders from around the world.
We bring them to experience 15 frontiers
of tomorrow from contemporary art to
biology, significant collaboration
with the United Nations.
And we try to hatch every year a
project that can scale rapidly and the
developing world and address one or
more of the sustainable development
challenges.
And so this gets back to this notion
of how do you capture the energy of the
grassroots creative movement and,
and help guide it towards sustainability
of the human condition in the long
time. That has always been
our biological self interest.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
and not sure how we do
questions and answers,
but I'd really love to talk with you.
I'm curious what your thoughts are.
If you've looked at this difference in
the creative space between people who are
kind of like the visionaries
and how this idea like, oh,
this product would be really cool.
And then they assemble a team of people
to get that done versus the creatives
who are more on the side of
like the actual people who
are building the products
and creating the technologies and kind
of like what the different qualities of
people on those different
sides of the equation.
Yeah, absolutely. And you know, if you,
I find always helpful too.
So the question for those of you who
didn't hear that clearly is how do you
combine the visionary with the,
the creatives who are bringing
vision to, um, to practice.
And a,
I think implicitly you're suggesting
that as I kind of did that they're really
different qualities that lead
to success here in sexist here.
And often those cultures
don't really mix very well.
And of course this has been
true throughout history and um,
and uh,
um,
I think today in the highly
specialized world that we live in,
uh, and the way we educate,
um, and organize ourselves,
the barriers between those two,
um,
sort of cultures are greater.
Um,
I think that very successful,
uh,
cultural innovation
environments and I view
Silicon Valley would be an
example of such an environment.
Boston maybe for biotech, New
York, maybe for Broadway theater,
the tend to create
sub cultures.
And I think that generally
you have a learning culture.
We're visionaries often sort of thrive.
You have an experimental culture where
people can fail and get paid for it
actually.
And you have a environment where people
produce and that any of those are sort
of relatively easy and you find them
in many, many places. It's very hard.
How hard would it create a culture where
ideas and people move between them and
where there's a trust that
allows that to happen.
And that is the sort of Pixie dust of,
um,
creating tomorrow. And again,
it's something that I talk
more about in the book.
I think that to be a little
bit more concrete, uh,
partly because of the nature of the
world that we are living in today. Um,
and, and, and, and, and, and frankly, uh,
the risky nature of the world we're
living in today probably has a lot more to
do with our evolutionary conditions.
Then the world of big offices
and kind of shore paychecks.
Um,
we can sort of,
uh,
okay,
thrive less well with the luxury of
considering myself a pure visionary or
considering myself a pure,
yeah. Applied kind of, um, uh,
a creator and we're
needing, um, all of us to,
uh,
tolerate and thrive in the
conditions of pioneering, um, uh,
vision, uh, as well as, uh,
being engaged in the complexity of sharing
that vision with others and learning
from others.
So the ivory tower is, is under, um,
I don't know if it ever really existed,
but it's very hard to
rationalize today and, uh, and,
and I think honestly it's very hard
to be a visionary and not be, um,
engaged in what you're describing as
that creative sort of exchange with the
public.
It used to be,
we understood better what people
needed and I think increasingly we need
everyone to show,
to tell us that.
So I'm hopeful that those two
cultures are coming together and a,
and in any case, I think environments
need to do a lot to just help, uh,
both sides. Um, communicate.
Hi. Um, so I agree with you there.
There's a lot of exciting
empowerment and personal creativity,
but at the same time I see
increasing trends toward, um,
short term rewarding short term gains,
um,
shorter and shorter products
like product life cycles,
which is where we get these piles of
trash and, and so, and so how does,
how do we start to shift?
Yup.
Okay.
Towards our culture valuing
longer term contributions. Yeah.
That seems like a real challenge
to this. Yeah, no, absolutely.
And as was true in the
Italian renaissance,
any sort of renaissance period, um, on
the one hand we like to talk about, um,
the heroes of the renaissance. But it was
a very tough time to be living things.
Everything was got to,
gave vague and all of the institutions
were pointing us in the wrong direction.
And that's even more profoundly true
today. And so it's hard to look at, um,
anything almost in the
media, uh, and uh, uh, if,
if nowhere else, and not
realize that, uh, the,
the qualities that I'm highlighting,
um,
and that I believe are really critical
to creating a world we all want to live
in, are not, um,
very frequently the qualities that are
being propagated in our institutions.
I think one of the things that I'm saying
for sure is that those qualities of
short termism are not sustainable.
Right?
And so I'm personally less interested in
spending my energy and figuring out how
do I kind of wake people up to,
and just,
there are a lot of people
who are awakened and,
and I think that in the
spirit of the pioneer, um,
I prefer to be with those pioneers making
tomorrow. And just assuming that the,
uh, those who, you know, the, the
unsustainable activity here, we'll,
we'll stop at some point.
I had a similar question to gold on,
on his,
about a short term thinking long
term thinking. We have a lot of, uh,
many institutions including
the government in the u s ray,
you elect officials every four years.
Companies like Google,
you have a annual quarterly performance
reviews and things like that.
You have to show some
progress towards a goal. Uh,
how do you bridge that gap between
sort of needing to show some short term
progress,
short term goals in the long term
kind of solving longterm problems?
Like asteroids hitting hurts.
Yeah, 20 years from now, 50 years.
So the great question, and I, um,
as I also write about in the book,
um,
and maybe did not emphasize
enough here, I am not, um,
I don't believe personally that the
value that a Harvard University brings to
the world or a Google brings to the world,
both institutions being under extreme
pressure to deliver value today.
Um, and, uh, this semester or
this quarter, uh, and both,
however, being highly invested in, um,
yeah,
the future of 30 years from
now. Uh, so there's, uh, uh,
the big question, which is
what you've just asked, well,
how do you balance the fact that we do
have students showing up the semester?
They really do need to take a class.
And maybe it's true that we
need to rethink education
completely, but meanwhile,
you've got students,
you've got to teach today and you can't
tell them what we're figure if you get
out. Right. And so that's
Kinda the issue. Um,
so I think what defacto is happening,
uh,
and it explains my role at
Harvard University. Um, and,
and, uh, I think, um, from my
understanding of Google and, and,
and a lot of the, uh, sort
of California tech, um, uh,
technology scene,
sort of enlightened leadership that is
giving space to whether it's giving all
of you time to think out of
the box or letting you, um,
sort of create a company
and move off campus and,
and sort of creating these sort of
experimental sandboxes where, uh,
we can dream about the future. Um,
and that itself is relatively simple.
What's difficult actually is
how to create that sandbox.
We're not only do you go off
and sort of think long term,
but what you do matters to me back here.
So that's the bigger issue is how do I
stay in touch and not lose sight of you?
Wow. How do I keep carrying? And that is
really an enlightened leadership issue.
And I, I think getting back to this
point that I tried to make earlier, um,
the good thing about where we're at right
now is that it's so urgent that we pay
attention to the longer term future that
we kind of just can't afford to send
you off to think about the
future and then forget about you.
And so I think that there's
clearly an awakening,
a happening today that I am hopeful,
um, will lead to more of that.
But it is a complicated a balance,
um,
that I think all of us in
a way strike in our lives.
And if you think back childhood,
I have kids now 15,
17 and 19 and there I've learned so
much from them and I still do. Um, uh,
but if you think back on the qualities
that made you survive adolescence,
um, where you needed at the
same time to be profound,
the moment at local and at the
same time yet to think about,
I'm going to call us and I got to go.
And you had to kind to think,
and you were in this sort of,
that's,
that's really what life is about.
Right.
And I think that there's been too much
now for too long where we kind of assumed
that we'll that ended and then you kind
of, and then this w it's, it's, it's,
we need to balance all those things.
For sure.
I just want you to hear your
thoughts on AI in creativity.
I think with artificial intelligence
today we tend to kind of see more and more
of things that we are already thinking
and people that other people were
thinking.
But how you go outside the box
and how you see AI playing a role.
Belinda?
Yeah.
Well, again, the question of it, this
is another big, big question. And,
and uh, I think my innocence will
help simplify the answer. Um,
so
let me just first say that one of the
things I write about in the book and that
I, I, I'm experienced every semester with
my students is this first day where I'm,
uh, you know, presenting
the concept of the class.
You've got to create something that
matters. And, and, and I in one year,
and I write about this in the book as
student asks this question and this gets
asked every year in one form or another,
what if I don't have an idea? You know,
and uh,
that the compliment to that is the
student who says d and then the next day,
but I found it online. Everybody
knows this is like out there already.
And my point to both of those,
uh,
young people is, is the same that, um,
if you were getting to
artificial intelligence,
I just want to finish this little thought
that I think what makes you matter,
uh,
no more than me in a certain way,
is that you own your
experience and I don't.
And that experience tells
you something about now, uh,
and about the needs and opportunities
now that only, you know,
and if from that you observe,
you're mindful enough to kind of
just notice and you have an idea,
I want that is coming from this intuition,
a lot of observations that you
could even articulate. And so, yeah,
we all want to create a wheel.
And then he said, well my God,
people have created wheels for a
long time. But I will say to you,
but forget about what people are great
and why the hell did you say wheel?
What is that mean for you?
And as you dig into it and you dig
into that Big Bank of knowledge,
which is intuition, uh, you will
have created something unique.
The a wheel. So I say all of that to
say that I think two things about it,
artificial intelligence from my
really distant perspective, one, um,
the obvious thing that really what's
happening is the national and artificial s
kind of merging and we're all,
because it's kind of,
we're going to be difficult to really
separate between the two and already is
right. The whole notion of consciousness
as being something that's biological,
it's crazy. It's clearly distributed. And
so clearly there's this merger going on.
I'm not fairly, so a big
issue in that is, is learning,
learning to adapt to this
drafted that we don't all learn.
So that's a huge issue. Um,
I think the second thing,
and this gets to thriving and
humanity and the long term,
I think that my intuition is that what
is happening here with the advance of
artificial intelligence is
what makes us human most human,
which is not probably the calculus
that I learned when we, well,
when I was like 20 years of age.
But it's actually that intuitive
bank of knowledge of my moment,
right? I own that. And I
own that in a way that, um,
no computer, however smart who
wasn't there can now. Right.
And so being able to mine that, uh,
and you know, it's, as, you know,
as we're advancing so rapidly towards
the future of artificial intelligence and
present,
we're discovering that biology is like
a black hole in terms of the complexity
and, and a sophistication
and a, you know, so I, my,
my guess is that there will be
a, a coexistence, uh, again,
not without pain. Uh, and, and I think
there are a lot of issues, as I say,
I'm related to equity and how we,
how we manage this. Okay. I'm,
I'm trying to really hard to resist the
temptation to just Mander and ramble. Um,
I'm going to try to make this
as short as I possibly can,
but it sort of piggybacks off of Tom's
comment, and I don't know your name,
but the comment you had after, um,
and something you said about, uh,
the Italian renaissance.
I recently read the,
the new biography of Leonardo Da Vinci.
And one of the things that struck me was,
and this was according to the author,
like how often that he had a patron who
just gave him so much leeway and so much
time,
and then he spent the time just doing
whatever he wanted or moving on and not
procrastinating. And, um, you know, he,
he left angry patron after angry patron.
Um,
but that freedom that he
had to do whatever he want
led to two or three amazing
masterpieces and a lot of sort of half,
you know,
a lot of half finished
stuff, a lot of, um,
exploration and, uh, as, as, um,
the other two commenters alluded to now.
And as you said now, like we're so
goal oriented and so quarterly goal,
yearly goal focused that I know you
said in response to both of those,
the policy is not like, I guess the focus
of what you're thinking on with this,
but it does seem like a natural,
like next step to,
to seem like how can we unlock
more potential from people?
There are a lot of creative people.
How do we unlock that?
I respond to that. Yes. Okay, cool. So
that's it. Now, you know, I, I read that,
in fact, I, I go more
into this in the book. Uh,
take Leonardo, um, as you say, the, the,
the Patriot and what I call activator was,
uh, played a big role. Patrons
look different today. It's true.
We have the Larry Pages
and we have the bill gates.
But the radical change in patronage,
a few wells that's gone grassroots.
And so those are kind of, but, but
activators, um, are everywhere.
But the activators matter. Um,
and uh, the second thing is this,
what I called culture lab in Florence.
He was super lucky to have been born in
Florence, but he was born in Florence,
right?
So there's all this stuff going on and
experimentation was being invited and,
and there was a culture that could look
at the experiment of the Duomo and call
it beautiful,
right?
And so there was this
ability to see the new, uh,
as, as, as potentially being very
beautiful. And so it invited.
So there's a culture, uh, that mattered.
And finally,
Leonardo would be a real sort of model
of the kind of dimensions that I'm,
I'm sort of referring to.
And so we do need this, um,
environment that,
uh,
includes people willing to bet on you.
Um,
and,
and to particularly bet on your ability
to realize the dream that matters to
more than you.
Uh,
we do need you to be surrounded
by those who can appreciate it.
Um, and, and, uh, and we, we,
we, we do fundamentally need,
um, you tried. So I
think that while again,
getting back to the earlier point,
uh,
we are in and you are here at Google and
I am to the extent that I'm at Harvard
in environments where
you see a lot of the, uh,
kind of the success of the last 20,
30 and maybe more years,
kind of an an inertial wave that
we're part of that may be a little bit
overwhelming, particularly we try to
move away from it sort of my role.
It just got to give good
care of Gulag. But, um,
that fortunately that is not the
whole of human experience right now.
And I think that all I can say,
which is kind of how I
manage my relationship with
Harvard University for Super
Delighted and lucky that
Harvard is still, um, um,
calls me one of their faculty members.
Uh,
but I spent a lot of time away and I spend
a lot of time in my own space. And, uh,
I think that,
um,
depending upon who you are and the
kind of pioneering you want to do, uh,
an enlightened, um, organization,
I'm sure Google should
give you that space. Now.
It's just important to understand that
Leonardo let a really risky life be any,
he was gonna not happy a lot of the time.
And he was kind of,
I didn't feel he was getting credit.
He had a lot of stuff.
And so being out alone is, there's a lot
of these had realized that, you know,
hanging by your fingernails is it,
it looks great when you then kind
of got to the top of Mount Everest,
but you're mostly hanging from his
fingernails and, and you've got to me,
I personally feel that that's, we
need to, I'll do more of that. Um, uh,
so, uh, that was a rambling
response to your rambling question.
Well, I have a very directed
short followup. Sorry.
What are some of the interventions,
I guess specifically you mentioned the
foundation that went to Cambridge and
then, you know, I know in your,
I'm sure in your development of insulin
that you had opportunities or things
that unlocked that ability for you. Yup.
Um, and so I was just wondering like,
without getting too much
into the weeds of policy,
like what are specific things you've seen
besides what you've already mentioned
that, that have worked for, you know,
people who maybe otherwise would
not have had the opportunity?
Um, well, let me say that
in, um, in, in,
in my case, um, and I get,
I write quite, you know,
I write about it in the book. Can I also
point this out and other creator lives?
Um,
I have found that in pursuing,
um, my dreams to the extent that my
dreams mattered more than just to me,
uh,
I have very frequently come to the edge
where this could be the it and I always
found, uh, someone, uh,
who came and helped.
And this notion of activator,
which obviously in the
Italian renaissance, there's
some really famous ones,
but they're everywhere right now.
And one of the great joys
of my own creative life is
the discovery that I'm not
alone, and that there's this kind
of network. Uh, and, and so that's,
and, and, and so in the
inhaled insulin case,
I was a theoretical guide,
written a couple textbooks.
I had five people in the world had
read and published this article.
And I had a series of people,
um,
if venture capitalists I mentioned who
was more than a venture capitalist who
played a really big role in my life,
but many, many, many, many people.
So is there a recipe? Um,
I don't know. I mean, I,
I have lived for many years in Paris and
have had lots of conversations with, um,
the French government
and academia in France.
But how do we create like Harvard in,
in, you know, pair? Is it an endowment?
Is that what we need? You
know? And so my big point,
and maybe this is the most concrete
thing I can say, there are,
there's an amazing education in, in
France and in many ways and, and, uh,
really just such bright people
and such a rich culture.
But one thing that is,
um, that's not thrive, uh,
they're speaking really generally
is as a student. Uh, when I, uh,
leave a university,
there's,
there's not a possibility to take a
big risk. And, and, and, and, and, and,
and do really, really well. I'm really
quickly, I mean it's more of a, uh,
a climb the ladder kind of phenomenon.
And I think that the,
um, the, the creating
of opportunities, um,
for the dreamers is, is the, the most
important thing that we can possibly do.
And I think it's,
it is a challenge for a big successful
organizations to create those because
it's hard to measure the value of the
little experiment in the context of the
big, big mission. Uh,
but, but that betting,
and maybe I'll, I'll finish by
just saying that in a, I was just,
just in Atlanta speaking to some people
and, and, and the question was, well,
what can we most do to like
do our kids, you know, and to,
to help them create a world
that they want to live in.
And I'm kind of create what matters in
my point to them against the point I made
in the book is that the best thing
we can do, I think to our kids is,
is help them see that they matter,
right?
And so I think that you can't create a,
anything that matters if,
if you don't feel you matter
first. And so that, uh,
mattering for me has generally been
people from my dad to lots of people,
my wife, lots of people who've
kind of bet on me in a certain way.
And so you matter. And so
that's, that's the, uh,
maybe the easy answer. What
does it mean to matter? Uh,
what does it mean to matter? Well,
as I say a, it's a little bit,
and I say more in the book, almost
anything matters at some moment, right?
Every drop matters at some moment,
right? And so that everything matters.
So it's a provocation.
But what it means in the title of my book,
these are things that matter,
not just to you,
but to many and for a long period of time.
And so a way to translate that a little
bit before even that if you dig into,
it's kind of, but they matter so
much that people want them to endure,
right?
And so they will help them endure.
It's like what you want of your
kid when your kid leaves home,
you want the kid to thrive,
right? You want every,
and that's not just your girl being,
you know, really entrepreneurial,
but people wanting her, you know, some
people wanting her in the room, people.
And so,
uh,
creating something that
matters is creating something
that's alive and that sort
of has a right to live.